from that moment on I knew we spoke the
same language doesn't matter if we had
disagreements too saying the other our
drive to win like we have to win there's
there's no other option
you can't just cuz the ship sinking all
of a sudden would jump off a swim into
another [ __ ] like that you don't do that
right you can win championships in front
of everybody then you can miss the
playoffs in front of everybody the most
important thing is curiosity first I
want curious people motivation watch the
top 10 with believe nation
he's fully frying and here's my take on
his top ten roses success volume 5 enjoy
[Music]
here's one of practice was important me
not from the justice standpoint that I
enjoyed playing like I enjoyed being
there I enjoyed getting better but as a
leader of a team it's also your
responsibility to elevate the rest of
the guys and what people tend to get
stuck on a lot they're saying okay the
way to make players better there's the
pass on the ball when they're open
that's a very trivial way to look at
things but you have to do is you have to
get them emotionally to want to be
better you want you have to get them to
an emotional space where they wake up
every morning driven to be the best
version of themselves right how do you
do that and in practice for me it was a
chance to drive them to challenge them
right if they're and this is where you
have to know your teammates because if
it's late you just had two back-to-back
and we had practice the next day and you
show up guys don't feel like going
through the motions don't feel like
practicing it's important to know each
and every one of them individually
personally because then you know what
nerve to touch some guys it's like okay
koalas know we can do this that'll get
them going
other guys know you got to figure out
what button to push you know pal was
always Spain if I tell them how they
lost in a gold medal to us and how
they're gonna lose again I'm gonna beat
your ass in practice just like I beat
you in a gold medal game all that all
you Tate that you hate that but that's
what practice what you have to drive
them absolutely have to and if practices
more intense and harder than a game
seven will be then a game seven will be
easy but if it's not then that's when
teams start folding and capitulated rule
number two watch lost wondering what I
love about you eighty others as he
wanted it
a lot of guys on our team didn't want it
but you wanted to add a a teeny on it
and that's why in the Utah game
everybody talks about this airboats I
wasn't mad at you that's why I was the
first one to come grab me and say hey I
know everybody's laughing and giggling
that but one day people will fear you at
the end of the game so I knew that about
just 1830 older you know was it was fun
rule number three excellence have you
noticed a moment where you're like I
can't maybe I can't be as intense as I
was during sports I can't demand people
to be here till midnight or practice
without a ball for three hours or no
listen my thing is really simple here is
that you know I expect excellent work we
all do so I don't care if you're here in
the office at 6 a.m. and you leave at
midnight if the work that you do is
average this is not the home for you
conversely you cannot be in an office at
all and have excellent work this is the
place for you so I don't really care if
you're here there's a lot of guys that
get in the gym and work hard work hard
work hard work hard but then they can't
transition that to 7:30 yeah right what
it was like for you with all of the grit
and all of the makeup that you had to be
such a great competitor what was it like
for you to play with people that that
weren't as gritty as you were how did
you deal with that how did you set your
expectations knowing that that you were
so far out there and and how did you
deal with the players that you played
with you know when knowing that they
they were still kind of somewhere on the
spectrum but but you're on the top of it
good question it's a great question um
my response might sound a little tough
but I just I come on my burial
you know this is you know tolerance for
that and the kind of culture that the
Laker organization stood for when in
Championships is not tolerated you're
gonna show up to play and you're gonna
allow the gags through the scrimmage
through this drill I'm going to beat you
I'm going to let you know I beat you I'm
gonna want you to reconsider your
professional life choice for the most
part people will say okay that doesn't
make a great teammate well I'm not gonna
be a great teammate I'm here to help you
win championships so here's the
difference and you know fortunately for
us for me you know we had an
organization that it was Championships
or nothing and they were really good
about identifying that and bringing
players in here that had that
competitive streak and getting rid of
the ones that denied if I got a fight to
get you in the gym that's a problem
that's a problem you want players that
are gym rats players at wanna be in the
gym that wanna work and then from there
you build on top of that but if you're
lazy man I don't want to talk to you I
won't deal with you you don't make me
feel Dumber you know you know you're
gonna lower my level I don't think so
you can go over there there's plenty of
teams in here where you'll fit right in
that's what you mentioned at the time
they were right down the hall from us so
he's your hunt
they were also if you want to learn how
to build confidence like Kobe Bryant and
others check out my 254 series the link
is in the description below it's free
and you'll love it if you wake up in the
morning and you're dreading going to
work dude do something else do something
else and those are hard decisions to
make but when you make those decisions
it's a very liberating experience or to
go play someplace else to try to chase a
championship that's not me man that's
not being that's not what my career has
been about there are certain things that
we want to get to but we have to pace
those out because we have to have
absolute focus focus on weighs 96
through 99 was the first rating point I
don't know but well maybe a little bit
for you but for me being one of the best
babes in the league and having that
title of not winning one I remember one
day reading it reading it in the paper
oceaxe averaging twenty or thirty of
doing this and the great Kareem
abdul-jabbar said well he didn't win
then yet
so is he great and I just kind of I just
kind of yeah you know why I wanted it
you know I understood it was a necessity
to have to win one there's a lot of
pressure and I think there's a lot of
frustration because you kept seeing this
kid and everybody kept saying could be
patient with this kid be patient with
this kid you're saying listen I don't
have patience I have to win now and this
kid needs to develop now I think I could
remember the first time we had our first
fight and you look this that okay this
crazy yeah we're sick we I was we're
playing a pickup games or a lockout
season Southwest college playing a
pickup game we're on opposite teams run
and trash talking yes and you kept
saying yeah take - hello take that
little boy I'm looking around oh yes
right ain't gonna be too many more those
low then would you say well what you
gonna do about it what you wanna do
about it and then at the next thing I
knew I saw a big hand coming this way
and I remember going this way I remember
throwing some lollipop olden Polynice
game
and then they all just kind of broke his
part broke us out I'm looking at this
I'm saying right he wants to stay he's
it's it affects him
I mean he's consumes him and then from
that moment on I knew we spoke the same
language doesn't matter if we had
disagreements to saying the other our
drive to win like we have to win there's
there's no other option we're going to
figure this out we won't get this done
and
[Music]
rule number six love what you do you
explain that mindset of just trying to
continuously improve I enjoy what I do
you know this is fun for me
you know III truly love what I do and
that's where the passion comes from
that's where the will to get better
comes from it's just because I truly
enjoy I enjoy the preparation the high
school coach Greg Donner it says that
you might actually be a little
embarrassed by how much you love
basketball yeah is that true
frog yeah I mean well it's like well I
mean it's like anything you know I I
just so happened to be playing
basketball like if I was a computer kid
you know in high school people would
have probably been in front of me you
know what I mean it just so happened to
be basketball what I'm passionate about
my passion knows no bounds but it
embarrasses you well I mean just a
little a little weird a little strange I
mean when you're around like in the
Olympics oh I'm around all the athletes
who kind of share that same shame my
same mindset it's it's fun to be around
though because you can have
conversations about those things 7 Joe
Johnson
I know it's good to say do you want to
win the championship everywhere but it
probably wasn't really a realistic one
so how do you would adjust how do you
adjust as a team leader and then how
about what conversations does ownership
have with the coaches and rebuild the
teeny gene ooh so sweet
she saw me worked so hard for so many
years and the last few years her and Rob
was at the time my agent called me and
said listen we are so sorry for what
happened to this team we're sorry that
we don't have seriously it's like we
don't we're sorry we don't have a team
around you that can contend for a
championship yeah so it's it's so we
could make a few calls and get you on a
contending team if that's some case we
just feel horrible about seeing you go
on out there in Chicago
remember this and and I said they're not
listed I said you know we've known each
other for a very long time
up now I'm questioning myself because
I'm wondering what about me as you think
I would jump ship we don't do that like
the Lakers I've been a Laker fan since
five years old man I could I know the
Laker history all way from Minneapolis
always with us today and so it's in my
blood and this family her father
believing in me and standing by me and
also stuff like I'm not I don't go
anywhere like this is home to me you
know we work through this stuff together
and like as a leader you I'll be able to
take the good with the bad
man you can't just cuz the ship sinking
all of a sudden I'm gonna jump off a
swim to another [ __ ] like that you don't
do that right you can win championships
in front of everybody then you could
miss the playoffs in front of everybody
you gotta be able to take boats out rule
the race learn from the best remember
the first practice we had Travis Knight
on the team and I mean you proceeded to
just annihilate this kid and you know
just from everything from talking trash
to him to you know he was afraid to get
on the bus and one thing that I noticed
about you from the jump was that you
didn't respect people that you could
bully and respect them and you test them
and you'd see what they let you get away
with and you'd see if they would fold to
that and that was the first thing I
observed about you and that competitive
fire that you had and then it all
started making sense that's how I see
him play with that rage when it comes
out that's how I see guys when you play
they back away from it afraid afraid of
that that confrontation that's
physicality and and then I remember you
taking me down to Jerry's deli back in
the day we had the big big flip phones
you know I mean
I have one no you have one point I said
hey get one of those that's pretty damn
cool yeah you know the big joy and just
hanging out with you men and you showing
me the ropes from day one curiosity
first what are the characteristics that
you're looking forward to bring into
your team is it much like you want a
teammate for the Lakers those type of
course or what are you what are you
looking for supportin thing is curiosity
first I want curious people people that
ask questions that want to figure things
out figure out new ways to do things you
know that's the most important thing and
then from that curiosity having a
determination to see that curiosity
through all right to figure out those
steps and if you figure out okay this is
a particular course of action that we
feel like we should be taking has it
been done before no but that's exciting
to me let's figure it out those are the
characteristics that I look for first
and foremost is inspire the people next
to you the final question is what's your
definition of greatness I think the
definition of greatness is to inspire
the people next to you yeah I think
that's what greatness is or should be
it's not something that's that that
lives and dies with one person it's how
can you inspire a person to then in turn
inspire another person but then inspires
another person and that's how you create
something I think lasts forever and I
think that's our challenge as people is
to is to figure out how our story can
impact others and motivate them in a way
to create their own greatness and cope
we on how to create forever that I
really think you're going to enjoy but
before that is something the three-point
landing questions time from just
watching another video and taking action
in your life for business here we go
question number one who are three of the
best and you will commit to learning
from number two what has your curiosity
been telling you that you need to start
listening to and number three who's next
to you that you can inspire as well we
talked about setting limits and
artificial limits and beliefs on
ourselves
granite II Studios what does the word
granite II mean
that means greater than infinity and I
just took those words and then made in
the word a hum and the whole idea is
that you know when I started playing the
game everything was about trying to be
the best when this meant you know when
it's made championships as you can
yada-yada yada-yada you get older you
start to understand that really it's
about the next generation that these
championships do come and go right and
there'll be other people that win
championships but the most important
thing you can do is to pay everything
that you've learned forward to the next
generation to come and that's truly how
you create something that lasts forever
right and so the fundamental belief of
the company is create forever now how
did you do that and that's how you
create something that's greater than
infinity inspire one who inspires the
next inspires the next and on and on you
go and that's the foundation of it all
if you want to learn how to have coedes
incredible work ethic check out their
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you that will never take a
night off even if it wasn't calling well
it was always going to be trying to slay
the dragon